Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for the 32nd episode!
32nd.
Is that short?
32nd, that's right.
32nd, is that short today, huh?
Not the 32nd episode!
It's very, very short format.
Goodbye!
A short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's not 30 seconds today.
No, not today.
Maybe another day.
Has there been any Ruffians?
Ruffians!
Have you seen Perroccino?
I think there's been some sightings.
Some?
Let's see where we found them again!
De-den!
It seems like maybe Pero's gone to a very far away place.
A vacation maybe?
At least, I guess this Ruffian must have went on a fun vacation and spotted Pero at some ancient ruins.
I don't know.
What's he doing?
Exploring!
I don't know.
Do you think that maybe he saw us playing Amnesia and Foreborn together with Advent?
Maybe he felt inspired for adventure?
I don't know!
I don't think it's a really good idea, huh?
You know, bad things can happen when you go adventuring in ancient and undisturbed tombs, you know?
But, I don't know, he does look very into it.
Yeah, it's good to have fun, right?
Look at the getup he has!
Maybe he just really likes ancient history.
Maybe.
It seems like Pero has a whip there, too.
I don't think he needs that.
That's just a bad idea, too.
His tongue is bad enough in the first place, too.
You know, but he could just use that to save himself, you know.
Tongue, yeah.
Or maybe fly away, too.
But I guess Pero is pretty heavy for his tiny little wings, right?
Yeah.
Pero's kind of more... He's the kind of Pero... The kind of Pero that would rather take the easier way to travel, I think.
Especially in the hot place like this, right?
Hopefully those wounds are everything he hopes and dreams for.
And hopefully he doesn't bring a curse back to us.
Pero Jones.
He doesn't have a last name.
He's just Pero.
Pero.
Pero is Pero.
Perroccino.
Full name.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We hope, Ruffian, that you didn't spot anything else disturbing at the moon.
The only disturbing thing is Peron.
Peron is get up there.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Do you know what happened recently?
Guess what?
Yesterday, we reached a really big milestone!
Yeah!
We reached 600,000 Ruffians!
Ruffians!
YouTube subscribers!
Thank you so much!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
We're so thankful for all your support during these last two months since we debuted.
There's been so many fun things we've done together.
And somehow it feels a lot longer than two months, but also sort of strangely short at the same time.
It feels like an in-between.
Do you know what we mean by that?
Ruffians, do you feel the same?
It's long.
A lot's happened, but it's also gone by really fast.
Do you feel that way?
It's weird, right?
It's weird.
Yeah.
Long but short.
Time is funny, huh?
Ruffians, we're really so happy to have you here with us.
We hope that you'll continue to let us protect your smiles for many, many years to come.
Is that okay?
Do we have your permission?
Hopefully we can make our family of Ruffians even bigger!
Even bigger.
Maybe we can get to 1 million subscribers.
Another big dream.
But first, let's aim for 700,000.
BAU BAU!
Big, big dream.
Thank you!
BAU BAU! 600,000.
It doesn't feel real, but there's more happy things!
We had some pretty cool announcements yesterday, but in case you missed it, we have...
Halloween Party together with Advent!
We announced it during our collab with Advent yesterday, right?
Yeah, we're gonna be having a big party, a big celebration leading up to Halloween Eve.
Yeah, we have a bunch of fun and spooky themes and activities coming.
I feel really curious about Shiori's pumpkin carving.
Tonight is 7pm, right?
7pm PT.
I wonder what kind of pumpkin she's chosen, right?
And what she'll be carving in it.
There's a lot of different types of pumpkins.
Yeah, because depending on the type of pumpkin you get, it can really change what you can do in the design zone.
I'm sort of curious if it's a tall pumpkin or a short pumpkin, a big one or a small one.
The white pumpkins too.
We'll also be having another announcement next Sunday!
And finally, on Halloween Eve,
We're gonna be having a Halloween costume party!
On the 31st.
Is that Halloween Eve?
It is!
It's not the Eve before Halloween?
No.
I'm confused.
But for our Halloween party, we'd really like it if you could share your spooky and funny Halloween hololive costumes with us using the hashtag #AdventCostumeParty.
And you know what?
BAU BAU!
I'm interested.
But you know, if it's okay... If it's okay, Ruffians, we'd also like to dress up too.
So if you have some cute ideas, maybe you could draw us a costume that we might wear during the stream and submit it with our hashtag.
Hashtag.
DressUpFWMC.
Will you?
I'm sure there's a lot of good costume designing Ruffians out there.
Yeah, but you can find pictures of us that you can draw on top of on Twitter too.
Just make sure that the costume is trans- The costume is transparent?
No.
That thought.
Image is transparent.
And the costume is there.
Yeah!
I stopped myself.
Yeah.
Are you proud of it?
Safe.
Safe!
Wasn't safe!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, there's a little bit of news.
News.
Maybe it's not quite the news you want, but... It's news.
There's news.
There's been some advancements in BAU BAU, Biou.
But it's not the good kind of advancements.
No...
You know, some Ruffians have been reporting that they've been experiencing serious nightmares recently.
The ones of a world without color and with a flower that's not quite right.
What do you mean Ruffians not quite right?
Fuwawa is always Fuwawa!
Right!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
You know, but Ruffians keep on muttering strange things like business as usual.
You know, I don't really know what it means, but it makes me feel sort of uneasy and a bit annoyed at the same time.
It's usual.
Usual?
Usual.
Ruffians!
It's BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
I'm concerned.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
I hope the Ruffians are okay.
Ruffians, maybe you just need to get some good rest.
Maybe the bad dreams will start to go away.
Exercise too!
You know, maybe we should let the Ruffians get some rest.
Sorry for all your wanting to play.
Will that make the BAU BAU view get better?
Maybe!
Ruffians!
Uh, there's... there's a misunderstanding again.
Again.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Unfortunately, Moco-chan wasn't really able to get over 3,000 and had to read a kind of embarrassing phrase.
They did.
Yeah, I know.
Ruffians, you're calling Moco-chan a baby?
Moco-chan, maybe you bubble bubble too hard.
No.
I'm not a baby.
I may get emotional and maybe I cry sometimes.
I might miss you and be needy sometimes.
But you know it!
You have eyes!
You have a brain, Ruffians!
At least you should.
You know it!
I'm a demon guard dog.
I'm not a baby.
I'm not Fuwawa.
I'm Mococo.
Okay.
Don't you misunderstand anything, okay?
I'm a full-grown puppy!
Yeah!
Got it.
Yeah, right?
You have a brain!
Put those bottles away, Ruffians!
We don't need the bottles here!
Huh?
No baby, just a little sister.
That's two.
That is two.
I am a full grown puppy, okay?
I'm a full grown little sister.
Understood?
It looks like the Ruffians have mainly understood.
You better.
You better!
Cause I'm warning you, this is a threat.
Got it!
I got it.
I'm glad at least you have it, Fuwawa.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Only happy stuff now, right?
Ruffians!
We just wanted to let you know, but you might be in trouble.
Just maybe.
A little bit of trouble.
You know, when Moco-chan mentioned that she likes to peek at the Ruffians' Twitter accounts, a couple of FUWAMOCO mornings ago, right?
And I got a lot of response from you!
Yeah.
A couple of Ruffians here, they're kind of concerned about what we might be seeing on their accounts.
Well... We might have some bad news for you!
You're in even more danger!
Danger!
It's not our fault.
You know, now Twitter is showing us your tweets.
From Ruffians.
Right on our timeline regularly.
In the 4U feed.
You're in danger!
Twitter is exposing you!
Without us doing anything!
So you have to watch out!
You never know what we might see.
Why?
Twitter's showing us things.
Yeah.
But... Moco-chan, what was that?
Nothing.
It was nothing.
Well, Ruffians, you know, it does actually make us really happy to see you getting along so well together.
Good friend, Ruffians.
It's really nice, you know, when we take a peek at Twitter and we're kind of a little bit tired and we see you all so happy together.
Yeah!
You know, you should be proud of what you feel passionate about, right?
You know, that's the FUWAMOCO way.
You're good.
You're good!
I'm very worried about what you might be seeing.
Why?
Sometimes it's not our fault.
Sometimes it's your fault.
Keep this in mind, Ruffians!
And sometimes it's Twitter's fault.
It's Twitter's fault.
BAU BAU!
It's a new week, Moco-chan.
And a new week means a new challenge.
Challenge ourselves.
So today, you know, Moco-chan is going to challenge eating natto again for the sixth time.
You know it's a spooky week.
Maybe this is a little bit spooky to Moco-chan, you know.
Right?
It's spooky to my tummy.
To introduce what natto is, natto is fermented soybeans and it's a very common breakfast food in Japan.
It's really healthy for you, but it's a little bit challenging.
Wait, stop!
I have to prepare for- No, can you not!
Don't interrupt me!
I'm trying to help you here.
Am I helping me?
Moco-chan wants to eat it because it's really good for you.
I do!
And then she eats it every day!
I do it!
She can be like her older sister.
And protect the Ruffian smile for many many many years.
I do want to eat it.
But you know, it's just like... I just... It's like, you know... It's when you have to do something big.
And you want to do it, you should do it.
You know you want to do it, but you don't.
It's nice and fluffy now.
Nice and fluffy.
I feel dizzy already.
Moco-chan, today... Today you're gonna eat it, right?
No.
Yeah, I will eat it.
Moco-chan, you've only... For recap, you've only got it in your mouth a little bit.
I ate one.
I will eat one.
Really?
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Was that last time?
I don't think so.
But I have ate one.
We took a step back last time.
I did eat one.
Ruffians.
Ruffians!
I did eat one.
Just to remind you Moco-chan, Moco-chan- She did eat one once!
She did eat one once!
I don't know.
But Moco-chan told Anya-senpai that you would eat a bean for her today.
So you need to ignore the fact that Anya-senpai is bad with natto too.
Okay?
Be stronger.
Stronger.
I am strong.
I've gotten stronger, right Ruffian?
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
It smells already getting to me.
It smells good today.
BAU Moco-chan!
First.
First Moco-chan.
We need to say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi.
Thank you!
They worked very hard to make this.
I'm sorry, I'm not good at it.
Here you go, Moco-chan.
Ow, it just bumped my elbow!
You know what?
The natto will make you feel better.
Thank you, farmer-san.
Thank you, yes.
It hurt.
I don't want to hurt you and make you feel better.
I'm gonna be eating an ass of it.
I'm not putting mayo on it.
I really can't do this today.
I really can't.
Even just looking at the stickiness is making me want.
It's nice and fluffy!
I feel dizzy.
I made it nice and fluffy, Ruffians.
You can do it!
For Anya-senpai!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
It's your sixth time today, that means six weeks of this challenge.
I do want to show improvement.
I do really want to show improvement.
I took a step back last time.
Don't say that.
You need to take a couple steps forward.
I don't have tea though.
No tea today.
Okay, I'm picking up a bean, okay?
I'm picking up a bean!
Okay, she has one bean.
Can you take two at least?
No, no, no.
Have confidence.
I am trying!
Do it for the Ruffians!
Fight on!
That's what I do every week, okay?
Moco-chan wants to inspire the Ruffians to challenge something hard too.
That's why you're doing this.
I picked up a bean, okay?
Okay, she has a bean.
In between the chopsticks.
It's losing the fluffiness.
You gotta hurry up.
Start with one.
We'll start with one.
Yeah.
Ikioide.
Ikioide ikou.
Just go.
With force!
Okay.
Passion.
Force and passion will help you eat it.
Okay, Moco-chan!
5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
Eat it, eat it, eat it!
Try it, try it, try it!
It has to touch your tongue!
It is!
Okay, okay, I'm taking the natto from you instead.
No, no, no, no!
Eat it!
Ouch!
She's frozen.
Moco-chan, eat it.
Eat it!
It's just sitting there.
I tried.
I didn't do it.
Moco-chan.
It just sat there.
That's not how you eat.
You don't put the food on your tongue.
Just sit there.
Mococo.
Moco-chan.
Another week of no progress.
You can do it!
Okay, let's try another video.
Do it!
I'll get one.
Oh, this is a small one.
It's a small one, Moco-chan.
No.
Yeah!
You can do it.
No.
I'm, I think, I think, okay, Ruffians.
I think I'm getting better with the taste, though.
The aftertaste, at least.
I think I'm slowly getting better, okay?
I found an extra small bean.
No!
It's extra small!
I didn't fail it, okay?
I didn't fail it because I think I'm getting better with the taste, okay?
Moco-chan.
I think I'm getting better with the taste.
I think I just, um, maybe, uh, need more rest first.
Rest up before the natto marathon!
This is not failure so far, okay?
I'm getting slowly better.
Okay?
It's just like... Moco-chan, if you don't hurry up, we're gonna have to discontinue this corner.
It's just like... It's just like the pup talk, you know?
One step a week, okay?
I've taken six steps.
I'm not there yet, but I'm taking steps.
Okay?
Moco-chan, should I show the Ruffians that I can eat it?
It doesn't matter, no one cares.
I'm gonna eat them!
No one cares!
Itadakimasu!
No one cares.
You're just eating food, no one cares.
It's yummy.
Stop.
We have to continue FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
I can't eat it all.
No!
It's yummy, Ruffians!
Thank you, Tochigi Farmers.
And I'll continue eating Moco-chan's leftovers later.
But Ruffians, please don't forget Moco-chan challenge.
Something she's not great at.
So...
Be proud of me, okay?
I haven't had water, I haven't had tea.
It's so yummy.
Good job, Fuwawa.
Thank you.
It's improvement, okay?
It's doing still.
BAU BAU.
It was an attempt.
We have a Doggie of the Day!
Important!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
This is Chika.
Chika!
Look at that expression and that pose.
That's shock.
It kind of reminds me of like an amateur graphic model in a way.
Why?
The shot, the angle.
The looking over the shoulder kind of.
Right?
Chika likes to eat tissues.
Like Moco-chan.
What?
Whenever you sneeze.
I don't eat tissues when I sneeze.
We'll make noises!
Moco-chan, you like to make noises too, right?
I never make any noises.
Not like the screams that you're making when we play with onions?
The last part there... I feel bad for Chica... I know... I know, Ralphine!
No
You don't say those kind of things when they're obviously not true.
Okay.
Poor Chika.
She's a lady.
She's very, very polite, I'm sure.
She does not do those things.
Ruffians.
Okay.
Slander.
Yeah, slander.
Moco-chan, how do we think this is BAU BAU?
I think she's sort of dainty.
Dainty?
She looks a bit shocked here, but dainty.
BAU BAU!
Really?
I think it's more like a nice regular head jump.
BAU BAU!
No.
Regular?
Regular.
Maybe a bit regular.
Standard.
Well, you know, I think Chika really enjoys being the best mom that she can be for the camera.
But, you know, obviously she's still kind of getting the hang of it.
You know, a few steps every day.
But we love that expression though.
It says a lot.
It says so much.
What do you think she's thinking?
And for our next corner we have... Today I went on a walk
Let's see... De-den!
Is this a walk?
It's a walk, you know.
A bit of a silly sight.
Seems like a paint can fell off a truck and left a kind of an explosion.
That's sort of scary.
Right?
It's like, I don't know, yeah.
Kind of scary, but intense and kind of cool too!
Right?
You don't really see this.
New art.
I hope everyone was safe though.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, I don't really know how they can clean that up, but it's sort of special, you know?
Right?
I think if it was us walking by and
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I got a very good question from a Ruffian.
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
You guys mentioned that you also auditioned for hololive JP.
If you guys got into JP instead of EN, how different do you think your content would have been?
BAU BAU!
It's a good question.
Very interesting.
It's true, you know, we did audition for JP when auditions weren't open for EN, but we just wanted to be part of hololive, you know?
But as for our content,
Ruffians, what do you think?
What do you think?
Do you think it'll be that different?
I'm curious.
Alternate reality?
A different world, my my!
Much less English.
Well, to tell the truth, I think it'd probably be the same.
It'd probably be the same.
Obviously, it'd be more often in Japanese than in English.
Yeah.
And we'd probably be a little more awkward and probably a little stiff, too.
When we speak Japanese, sometimes we can speak it a bit formally, a bit too formally.
But we're trying to loosen up, too.
Yeah.
You know, of course, we make mistakes all the time as well.
You know, right?
We've never tried playing a game and doing commentary in Japanese at the same time, so we don't really know if we'd be that good at it, but we'd like, you know, it'll be interesting.
At the very least!
We're really happy to be a part of hololive in the past, and we hope that we can make hololive even stronger!
But we'd also like to be able to use our Japanese skills more.
We really don't have much of an opportunity to do that, so we'd really like to if we could.
After all, you know, it's a skill we have just like any other skill.
We'd like to be able to make use of it, you know?
Otherwise, it's just a waste!
But we hope that we can bridge Holo JP and Holo EN together in the future, too!
A little step still.
BAU BAU!
Thank you again, Ruffians, for all your submissions today!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make all together.
We're waiting, okay?
We're waiting for your doggies.
We're waiting for your vlogs, your questions.
I'm Pero Sighting.
Please don't forget to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Well, let's take a look at our next dream.
Our next dream we have...
Donkey Kong Country.
But first, tonight we're going to be taking it maybe a little bit easier.
First, this is tomorrow Donkey Kong.
But we're going to be recording a bunch of stuff too.
But Ruffians, we would like to ask you to make sure to get lots of rest, okay?
Well, we'll maybe try to.
But like Moco-chan mentioned, we're going to be back tomorrow with Donkey Kong Country.
Yeah, it never seems to have failed to make us turn into big monkeys and go a bit bananas.
So, yeah, it can get pretty crazy.
A bit crazy, a bit bananas.
We hope we can get to even more levels next time!
We'll do our best.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
We have a bunch of spooky streams coming up this week, but we're really looking forward to our FUWAMOCO Rock N' Roar Party!
It's gonna be on Saturday, and this time, it's a Halloween special filled with songs that you might not really think of as Halloween songs.
Oh, but they're still spooky songs.
Definitely very spooky.
But we hope that you'll be able to join us for a Halloween night of howling and howling!
A bit earlier than Halloween.
A bit earlier.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm looking forward to it!
FUWAMOCO Week 1!
We hope you'll be there!
Please, please!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 32nd episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some Extra Special Ruffians!
Ruffians, you're too quick!
You're too fast!
Marina!
BAU BAU!
Jimmy!
Sylvie!
BAU BAU!
Matthew!
Remy!
BAU BAU!
Koekut!
Humie!
BAU BAU!
Shabon!
Panoramic!
BAU BAU!
Orange juice!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!